الاسباب عور هذه التحديثات هي التهديدات
الوجوديه
المرتبطه بالاسلحه النوويه
والكوارثه المناخيه
والجائحه
كما ان هنالك التقنيات التخريب يوم سما
بالاحلاليه فمثلا الذكاء الاصطناعي فهذا
يذكر الجميع
مدى قربنا من يوم القيامه او الهلاك وكل
اصحاب القرار عليهم ان يتذكروا دائما ذلك
وعندما يتاملون
هذا الوقت الضيق فسوف يتخذون القرارات
الجيده على سبيل المثال خلال الجائحه
عندما قدموا اللقاحات الجديده
تضافرت جهود العالم في الحقيقه تمكنا من
منع العديد من الوفيات والكثير من الاشياء
السلبيه
المفهوم مرتبط
بالانسانيه جمعاء ولكنها تركز بشكل اساسي
اللي نشر الوعي لاصحاب القرار واصحاب
القرار نقصد بذلك في كل دول العالم كل
دوله الان
تواجه الصعوبات المرتبطه بازمه المناخ
وكذلك صعوبات مرتبطه بالجائحه
واذا ما حصلت كارثه نوويه
فاثرها بالتاكيد ستكون عالميه
وهي الساعه رمزيه
اليوم هو مثل بناء اليقظه
هذه التسعون ثانيه قريبه جدا من منتصف
الليل في عام 91 وفي نهايه الحرب البارده
فلنساها عدت الى 17 ثانيه فقط من منتصف
الليل
او سبعه عشر دقيقه اما فيما يخص
فكانت ابعد بكثير اما الان فهي قريبه جدا
من منتصف الليل او بعشره اضعافها فقط 90
ثانيه من منتصف الليل
[موسيقى]